well a little chilly for ice cream this
morning but you know to each his own sun
is on its way up now we've got clear
skies and light northerly breezes
overall for the valley but boy they are
still bumping around down around
laughlin and bullhead city wind
advisories still issued for those areas
today mostly 30's around the valley it
is cold out there we've had a little
wind between parampa down around
freezing and the mountains in the valley
of las vegas so mountain spring summit
so a little windy there on the drive
we'll talk about what's going on in the
west which isn't much but we do have
some changes for the weekend as we look
at the eastern u.s oh my goodness it's
snow it's cold it's wind and it's going
to be a bomb cyclone hitting the east
coast this weekend new york city right
now already getting a little bit of snow
but wait until this low pressure hits
this weekend look how snowy and cold 30
degrees wind chills in the 20s and that
snow is flying around this morning new
york city could see six to nine inches
of snow further up the road to boston
they could see two feet of snow this
weekend as that low pressure system
moves up the coast and florida has
freeze watches and warnings some of the
coldest temps that they've seen in maybe
a decade in florida this weekend high
pressure in the west though not too bad
in fact it's keeping things pretty clear
it's even quiet up in the pacific
northwest but as we zoom in a little bit
this low pressure off the coast of
southern california will pull clouds
into our area starting late today into
tonight and definitely more for your
saturday so don't look for a whole lot
of sunshine tomorrow winds will continue
with that wind advisory along the
colorado river valley today and that
does include lake mead those winds could
be up over 40 miles an hour breezes to
about 20 miles an hour in the mountains
42 and sunshine for mount charleston 60
for the valley not too breezy for us
today and really through the weekend
pretty quiet but clouds definitely
around for saturday sunshine returns
sunday with mid 60s and beautiful finish
to the month but boy february blows in
with another cold front windy on pretty
much wednesday groundhog day and chilly
or mid 50's look at that groundhog
blinking in the wind